(audience cheers)
- I love these pants.
Okay. So, and joining us remotely,
give it up for Brendan Fraser!
(audience cheers)
(upbeat music)
What's up?
- [Brendan] Hi, Kelly.
- I know. He's here with us in spirit.
There you are.
Hi!
- Hi.
(Kelly laughs)
- What's up, Sadie?
Welcome to the show.
- Oh, thank you for having me.
- No, I'm very excited.
A fellow Texas girl, too.
You're originally from Texas, right?
- Yes.
- [Kelly] Yes.
I was born in Brenham, Texas.
- I actually know where that is.
Yeah, bunch of small
towns no one's heard of.
Texas.
So, Sadie, are you going to get
to spend the holidays with your family,
or are you going back
home or where do you go?
- Yeah, I'm gonna be with my family.
And we have some very
exciting holiday traditions.
- [Kelly] Wait, what are they?
- Christmas Eve karaoke is big.
- [Kelly] Yes!
- And then also we do a
cookie decorating competition,
and it's gets very competitive.
- I love your family.
- [Sadie] Yeah. Yeah.
- Now, does this end
poorly sometimes?
- Oh, yeah.
- Okay. (laughs)
- A few tears have been
shed in past years.
- My family is competitive, too.
My favorite part is my mother's like,
"You and your sister,
y'all are so competitive."
and we're like, "You're like
the queen of competitive."
She's like, she throws
shade better than anyone,
and like, you don't even
know what's happening.
Are you competitive?
Do you play games with
your family, Brendan?
- Full contact karaoke.
(everyone laughs)
- (sings) Should I stay
or should I go now?
(imitates crashing noise)
(everyone laughs)
- Okay. You just upped karaoke in general.
I love your version.
Well, to both of you,
do you remember the coolest
gift you ever received?
Like, when you were little?
- Probably an American Girl Doll.
- Oh my god, you're so young. (laughs)
- They were huge when I was little.
It was very-
It was very special.
- Those weren't even around
when I was a kid.
That's amazing!
Do you remember which one?
My daughter loves the American Girl Dolls.
- Oh, Kit. Kit Kittredge.
- Oh, Kit, yeah.
Love it.
All right, all right.
What about you Brendan?
When you were little, what was
one of your favorite gifts?
- Only doll I got was a G.I. Joe.
- (sings) G.I. Joe.
I remember those, yeah.
- He came with a parachute
built into his back.
- [Kelly] Yes.
- I threw him off the balcony
from the second floor,
and he got stuck in a tree
until the next spring.
He just kind of hung there.
(everyone laughs)
- I love that.
So he's still America's greatest hero.
So you're originally from
Texas, you were saying,
so what's like, something
you miss from Texas?
- Oh,
probably "y'all."
No one says "y'all" where I live now.
- [Kelly] Oh.
- And I miss that.
- I can't drop it.
I don't even know I'm doing it.
Especially when I drink, Sadie.
- Oh.
- [Kelly] Yeah. Yeah.
(audience laughs)
- Yeah, it's an issue.
It's like I get the twang.
Do you say like "light"
and "white", and like,
do you say "right" or "right"?
- No, I mean, honestly
the Texas accent was
bullied out of me once
I moved to New York.
- Okay.
- Around 10 years old.
- Oh, okay.
- So I dropped it.
- Yeah. You didn't want to
get beat up on the playground.
- Sometimes when I get on the phone-
Yeah.
- Yeah.
All right, I gotcha.
I just held on to mine
while getting beat up on the playground.
So, what do you think the most
Texas thing about you is though?
- I'm not sure.
Probably the y'all thing.
- [Kelly] Probably the, y'all?
I really shed a lot of, a lot of my-
- I'm gonna put it back in there.
What?
- Yeah.
I'm very sad right now, Sadie.
- You can help me.
- Okay. Yeah.
Whatever New Yorkers, we're cool.
(laughs)
Wait, so Brendan,
did you get to meet Sadie's family ever?
- I did.
- Yeah?
- At the premiere the other
night at Lincoln Center.
Did you know that she has 93 siblings?
(everyone laughs)
- Just four. I'm one of five.
- That's a lot though.
- Yeah.
- But they were all there.
- [Kelly] That's exciting!
- Yeah. Real deep.
- Yeah. Were they, did you like,
watch them watching the
premiere like, the movie?
- Yeah, I did. And a lot of them,
except for my mom were watching it
for the first time.
It's definitely a difficult
movie to watch with your family.
- [Kelly] Yeah, it's intense.
- Especially my dad, and
I was really excited for
the two of them to meet,
'cause it's a father-daughter story,
so it's a weird one to
watch with your own dad.
- You have a very different relationship
with your father hopefully than-
- Yes. Yes.
Very...yeah.
- Okay. (laughs)
- [Kelly] I was like, if
you've seen "The Whale"-
- I'm never, I'm never that mean to him.
- [Kelly] Yeah. (laughs)
- Your dad's a football coach.
He doesn't take trouble
from anyone, I get the feeling.
- Yeah.
- Oh my gosh, wait, you're like,
full on "Friday Night Lights".
- Oh, full on.
- Oh, that's amazing.
- Yeah.
- Football coaches in Texas are-
- It's intense.
It's a storm.
- In high school football, too.
- Yep.
The culture surrounding it.
- They don't think they're in high school,
they think they're playing pro.
- No no no.
The stakes are, they are so high.
- Yep. Yep.
That's how it is.
I remember being in the
stands in high school going,
no one's winning the
Super Bowl here. (laughs)
- But they might as well,
like it might as well
have been the Super Bowl.
- It is. I know.
Not downplaying it.
Just, they're very passionate
people about football.
So Brendan, had you seen Stranger Things
before you met on the movie?
- Yes, I have.
I saw the first season in its entirety.
I loved it 'cause I grew up
playing Dungeons and Dragons,
and the whole ensemble of
Stranger Things reminded me
of the crew that I used
to run around with when
I lived in Seattle, Washington
in the late seventies.
So it was nostalgia for me.
I loved it.
And then, after we finished "The Whale",
a certain Sadie Sink went on
to stare down a really scary monster
called Vecna.
(laughs)
And I know that's because
she had just come
from playing
Charlie's daughter
who has a great deal of
finely focused
anger issues with her father.
So I think Sadie
definitely carried her work
from one project into the other,
'cause that Vecna guy ran with
his tail between his legs.
And I know why, and it's not just
because her dad is a football coach
and has a handshake like a stone mason.
I know, 'cause this hand still hurts.
(everyone laughs)
- We're just trying to show our strength.
It's a power struggle.
So Brendan, we have to
talk about "The Whale".
Explain what it's about to everybody.
It's a very intense movie.
- Charlie's a man who's been living alone
in his two bedroom
apartment in northern Idaho.
He has certain life regrets
for choices that he's made
that led to him,
well,
his family fell apart.
He had fallen in love
while he was married,
and he started a new life
and left his daughter behind.
And he has clearly certain regrets,
and he has been harming
himself sadly by overeating.
And his health isn't,
is severe.
And he has five days really to see
if he can reconnect with his daughter.
It's a quest for
redemption.
- Redemption, yeah.
- As the story goes.
That's the film.
It was directed by Darren Aronofsky
who brought us "Black Swan"
and "The Wrestler",
and it was a thrill to work with
a world-class filmmaker like Darren.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- [Brendan] He really knows
how to call the shots.
- Yeah, and y'all do an incredible job.
Like, I mean you did so well.
You've been getting
standing ovations, like,
and, you know, people are just-
it's a very impressive
film to won. I just-
Do you take that home with you?
Like, that's the hardest thing.
Like even if I'm writing a song,
and it's like depressing,
and I'm getting through something,
I have to like get it out and let it go.
But every day you had to come back
and go back to these scenes
that were so intense.
Is that hard to shake when you go home?
- What do you think Sadie?
I mean we had three weeks to rehearse it,
which was really helpful.
So we really knew the
lives of these characters.
But I think if we took it home
it might have just been,
in my case, because I was
costumed in apparatus that
increased Charlie's body size,
that when I took it
off, I felt a little bit
weak-kneed or wobbly just because of,
I think, that new muscles
were activated in my own body,
and somehow it gave me
a sense of appreciation
for those who live with obesity
in a way that I was not expecting.
- Absolutely. I can't imagine
having to wear that every day.
So how did putting on the
300 pound prosthetic suit
change the way you look at the world?
- Well, it gave me a
stronger sense of empathy
for those who live with the disease.
And I know that
our work with the Obesity Action Coalition
was very helpful
to advise us about the film.
And overall, their mission
statement is to end bias
against those who carry
extra weight on their body.
And I think that it gave me a strong sense
of obligation to portray
this character Charlie
with the dignity and
empathy that he deserves.